hello and welcome to this video playing
I am a hot dress I cannot really do this
correctly Hawaii xie mulan's okay um yo
let's go it's their bird the bird eye
opening yeah this way of playing I have
recommended in the video earlier this
year and I believe it is a very sound
way of playing against them against the
bird and by the way it's not the birds
opening because it has something to do
with the animal it's named after that I
think English player Henry bird yeah
what white plate here is the reversed
stone wall so store with white nothing
that black is minding much I guess I'm
very happy that I can trade off all the
pieces here and at the end have that
excellent night okay I think I'll just
castle
yeah White's position um it doesn't have
many many prospects I wonder what he's
up to does he want to take on the five
or play c5 not sure about it I was
thinking about taking on e5 but D takes
d5 might be might be an issue I can also
just go f 5 which is very this is a very
simple way of playing let's let's keep
it simple my strategic threat is a bit
much but yeah okay I will take it
yet he takes d5 is just completely wrong
so because that can take on c4 he had to
play that and it's not my idea Scooby 5
tried to force some wow I don't really
understand what white is doing to be
honest you never get a get any sort of
attack on the Kings item quite quite the
opposite okay um so let's go to five the
main issues that is playing with the
with the piece down without the vision
won't be too
yes but I can still just take it right
let's take it yes to has to trade
everything here at the end this is a
very very nice ending check rook takes
Queen takes that screen f2 as a threat
so it cannot even take g4 and if it
takes you for now I'll take f1 with
check we have 17 f2 and should also win
immediately
yeah that's more or less losing for
white I think don't don't see a move a
simple plan is also just to take on f1
and go through Queen f7 or queen evade
okay so if i take and then just Queen f7
right Jay King takes that's 93 so this
is all of the picture Queen takes Queen
f7 that ending should win right I can go
to f5 yeah that should be winning Queen
g2 that's Queen f3 or any other Queens
yeah basically okay if I go 93 he cannot
move this bishop this is really really
funny before a five and they can
probably set up some kind of sucks long
as well
yeah he's running one who's got 92 now
one white resign yeah before I can play
the move um ok so let's have a look he
was very very yeah easygoing let's say
and giving me it strategically
advantageous position around here things
are probably not that bad but I was very
surprised that that he just played this
for example this is a surprising move if
he for example let's say he plays some
some non committal that group c 1 or
something like that in the situation um
here if I now for example start to trade
yeah and he he plays this for example
this this then he has some control over
the square and can maybe play you for
and the way it went after 95 the
upcoming sequence is totally forced i
can take this with the temple take the
two he has to recapture i get the night
24 and now i have this fantastic piece
them and I can even if I want already
take this which I wasn't sure about
because he can take with the deep horn
and sometimes this night is actually
looking good but it's not so clear how
well placed it is I was also afraid a
little bit of some some business with
the dis and otherwise i would like to
take i get the night only four against
somewhat somewhat bad bishop
okay I can I can do this first and now I
expected him to add some time maybe he
even retreat the night to d3 yard to
challenge the night with night f2 but he
didn't do it again I could take but I
felt okay let's be very convenient about
it and he simply does not want to
retreat and now it's the ideal situation
to take in six intending b5 I want to
open up the position of course I cannot
win if everything is closed yeah this
one be 5c five and yeah after g5 the
position is strategically very very bad
for what I ungry I don't think that you
can save it objectively anymore I just
go G 425 and end advance them even
simple King edge a droopy a drupe 26
Boog h6 or something like that would
work ok you tried this is this kind of
desperate counter play but I can just
see I take twice can ok then this is
technically speaking simple win the
computer gives even a stronger move yeah
this is in fact quite strong because
black has the whole F file under control
and I just threaten g3 queen age 5 and
so on I just threaten an attack it's
probably even more powerful even though
the ending it's very simple to win so
there was no particular point in making
doing anything anything fancy yeah the
cord is just getting getting lost yeah
it's just this is kind of stone wall
structure if you allow night to sit down
that cannot be challenged it's usually
not a good idea
so I think somewhere on t he definitely
should should place a move like this and
try to challenge this nye possibly take
it or make me retreat it allowing a
night against this Bishop is some is
strategically too risky ok thanks for
watching